what's the funniest thing that's ever
happened to you upset for H as his mum
when Jon Jon Snow and the cat yeah Jon
Snow Sam got stuck in the live and we
was having lunch was downstairs under
the ten and then it was like said the
the lift stopped and he kind of like
dropped side woods and we was all like
they were really anybody's like about
four hours in this and quite find that
big find that my economy and crank
something and obviously came down and
yeah but that was that was a place that
was quite funny but obviously he was
really you know worried about them now
he was it wasn't funny necessarily for
me but someone got kick out of it cuz I
was fully dressed up in my lovely
leather outfit for season one and it was
raining outside and the costume
department very kinda came in on brother
you know be careful as I can of course
I'll just skip from my trailer to the
studio so Shirley's five minute walk so
I'm walking on it you know really it's a
raining cats and dogs above us but I'm
keeping it all protected and then this
big car to sort of Jack to stone swooped
round the corner and nail speak complete
the nails make weird
like splashes all over me I'm just sort
of stood there going what stood this is
totally and the driver a really lovely
big big man gets hangers-on I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry it's all been get out of
that goes good that was funny that
son there's a little bitty please Anna
kilowatt very heavy nobody fish not
funny Ted story during during the
filming for the season if there's ever a
blooper reel and the ship began to
without giving away at the story I sort
of stopped up and word of danger by
saying older and it was the top of this
little hell and I stood up on us I still
have a cook I was my in the bottom of
this ditch the director who's a Michelle
time-limited Macario
their enemy fire
you